hey guys it's Dennis the founder thank
Hera and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 17 turn turn turn which is kind
of like a big big probably the biggest
episode since the premiere really
biggest episode in the premiere the
least watched episode ratings continue
to decline even this week it was
reported today but yeah it's the big
episode it's basically if you watch the
previous episode and this episode can
almost act as a bookends for the Captain
America to two movie I feel like I guess
you could kind of still enjoy the
episode if you haven't seen Captain
America it wouldn't mean as much and you
also would get spoiled for the movie so
if you haven't seen Captain America the
Winter Soldier yet you probably
shouldn't watch this review but then
again you probably shouldn't watch the
episode cuz you know both of those
episodes at least the first one before
Captain America they didn't spoil
anything they just had all these events
that kind of you know that's why I was
kind of mom about a few few things that
happen in the episode before but now you
know Captain America is out here it is
so yeah
Hydra hail Hydra so it directly ties
into the show so yes I what I was
worried about oh they're gonna not
connect the two but obviously they were
waiting all this time to do it yeah and
again that doesn't excuse the show I
think that's that's a fault of the
show's for being so heavily you know I
don't know hold it hold and behest yeah
the whim of their masters the great
Marvel Cinematic Universe and it's it's
a problem I mean this effort into all
the problems this episode was good it
was very intense and most I've been
entertained ever on the show I'm not
trying to be you know hyperbole here
it's just that it really was my favorite
episode of the season but it still
upsets me because they're so wrapped
around the Cinematic Universe this show
cannot stand on its own it can even with
the SIP episode I know you didn't like
this episode I enjoyed this episode but
that's still not the show and that's
what upset me whenever something like
this is good but it's because it ties
into Captain America too I enjoyed most
of this episode I'd probably say it's
maybe my second or third favorite
episode and probably third favorite
episode of the season yeah it was
entertaining
action directly tied in so the story was
a lot better a lot of twists and turns
there was a my only real complaint about
the episode was there was a lot of
exposition in terms of dialogue between
characters like hey I'm gonna have to
explain this whole thing
right so they couldn't go full-on
because they were trying to make the
show or the episode like hey if you
haven't seen Captain America - let me
explain
bro you right but at the same time it's
like well if you haven't seen Captain
America it's not gonna be quite as
enjoyable yeah even when agent hand is
you know when she's looking at the
screen you can see the helicarrier's
crashed into the buildings you know
scenes from Captain America - so yeah I
said it was entertaining like I really
liked the action sequence with them
after what's his ward kisses guy and
goes out and beats up all those guys
there was some good kind of arrow esque
you know good fight choreography you
know it was well made it was a good
episode Jed Whedon was one of the
writers but it's just yeah it's just
it's so tight in the Marvel Universe
like this show can't survive without it
I think it's like it's like every was
like oh this is an excuse it was
building up to this I'm like yeah we did
wait what sixteen episodes get to this
episode seventeen now so it's like it's
a long time to wait it is the watch I'm
hoping now that this is happened yeah
that now the show can move forward from
here well question what that is and not
that not the viewers here because you
folks either you watch it or you're not
you guys already committed but for
people who haven't in this series who
fell off like this was a still it was
reported a variety of many let's say
this is the lowest ratings it's like the
shows you're still dropping so it's like
this is the most important episode but
like my question is - everybody's like
who cares like there's anybody who's not
watched they're gonna jump back god I
think next episode will be maybe a
better test to that see people like okay
now that's in the movie let me see
what's going on now that shield is
broken let's see what yeah dismantled
actually like that storyline I love how
shield is dismantled as we saw in
Captain America Winter Soldier hydras
introvert infiltrated the whole shield
organization and maybe not everyone in
shield is a bad guy right at least a
good portion is and especially in the
higher-ups and maybe this it's gonna be
a more fascinating story with Coulson
and
hand leading this whole group and I like
bill paxton with bill Paxton's reveal of
him being a villain in this one you know
it wasn't to like it wasn't like a huge
huge surprise you know but I did like
wards yeah
reveal I'm actually interested in him
now for the first time ever I'm actually
interested in this character I'm curious
serious go so even though you know I'm
kind of criticizing the whole shield
franchise I actually did I really really
didn't enjoy myself why she's up so I
was like wow this is actually from start
to finish I wasn't bored I didn't look
away and go on my computer something
else I actually set there focused on the
TV the whole time I was really and I
enjoyed it it's a nice little companion
piece to Captain America the Winter
Soldier but I said you could almost I
know they won't do this but let's say
they're at least the blu-ray you could
almost like watch the first step last
week lo last week's episode watch
Captain America and then watch this one
and then he'd almost like like I said
like some nice bookends well speaking of
Ward and in Skye man that scene where
they're you know they're like he's like
confessing his love roses now you know
what that means now because he's a we
know he works for Hydra yeah yeah but I
mean it was pretty boring until the end
when you find out he's a bad guy then it
actually makes it a little more
interesting because when they first you
know when they kiss each other and like
talking about oh I want to take you out
for a drink and blah blah blah I was
like alright oh man boring but it's
actually more fascinating now yeah
because he is a bad guy and he probably
will continue this relationship with
Skye try and find out whatever her
secret is does she have a secret power
she has a secret past or whatever makes
her supposedly special I think that's
his goal yeah and I think he's gonna
continue that and hopefully that makes
for their relationship to be much more
interesting because of that versus the
typical hey here's to attractive people
love that don't really have anything to
say to each other cuz they really don't
yeah now he's gonna be a double agent so
I'm curious to see where the rest of
seasons gonna go we're almost there
towards the yang Katyn the last you know
quarter of the episodes here so I'm
curious now I mean I know if I love the
show I don't think I love it but I mean
I am curious now to see how it ends
because this was a good episode
a few episodes have been better than the
first half of the season for sure yes
for sure for sure
little convoluted this episode in terms
of light now trying to be like oh these
guys I don't like when shows or movies
do that well no just more like a like
hey we're gonna try and fake you out
type of stuff with hey this guy's a bad
guy oh no he's not
yeah like they did it with
what's-his-name the the the one guy with
Simmons oh yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
gonna stab yeah we're gonna hand her the
knife and then like I don't like that
it's just I find it to be really cheesy
the whole thing with Victoria Han like
okay she's sending for the the plane
back and thinking it's Coulson's the the
guy that's with Hydra but really it's a
Bill Paxton scary you know like I just
don't need all of that
I like grants reveal and twist because
it's been building in the sense of you
know his character has been here for 17
episodes it kind of makes sense like why
is he here he's always been a loner he
did train under what's Bill pectins
characters uh I can't remember
oh yeah he did train under him yeah so
it makes sense so for me that one wasn't
you know so bad but to have all the
other trying fake out stuff this was
that one was much more interesting yeah
that was good look I said solid episode
looking forward to see where it goes the
show still not deep it's not that
interesting in terms of depth of
character but Ward really needed a boost
this was his boost now I am now I am
curious about his character more than
maybe anybody else's on the show and I
think the stakes of the show are hiring
yeah finally have something to do really
frustrated is it took something in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for that to
happen it's not because the stakes in
the show this show are important it's
the stakes of shield from Captain
America from them from the movies and
that's what's frustrating but I have to
give credit where credit's due this was
a good episode I enjoyed myself watching
this so so you know next week is gonna
be a big indicator yeah yeah see if the
ratings go up yeah alright guys so let
us know what you thought of this episode
how do you think it
worked in terms of tying in with Captain
America the Winter Soldier hopefully you
saw that movie before you saw this
episode otherwise you're gonna be
confused because I got some tweets that
were like we're like Nick Fury's dead I
know I like it I'm like well he's not
because if you watch Captain America you
know that he isn't and therefore but
there's a reason why they think and I
think first before we leave I think
that's a fair point because Marvel can't
expect you know what's up with this a
show has to work in and of itself Game
of Thrones has to work for you you ever
read the books game which needs to work
on a per episode basis assuming you
haven't read the books but also do
little fanservice for the people who
have read the books it's a TV show
yeah she'll can't expect the whole world
I mean they want them to they want them
to I mean I guess it wasn't announced
today to they to surpassed Harry Potter
as one of the highest grossing domestic
films of all time franchises the whole
time but I mean yeah I mean like what if
you haven't seen the movie people or
busy people they have work they have
kids they have jobs maybe you don't get
to go see it till the next weekend so
it's like you know that's I feel bad for
somebody that's it seem cap yeah you
know yeah all right well let us know
what you think you poster constable on
the website think here calm or our
YouTube channel think hero Pro make sure
you subscribe to that you guys come chat
with us on Twitter or less than we
thought of Captain America Dennis and I
had a review out that's up right now and
yeah let us know we talked about this
episode of shield it's at think hero I'm
at Griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans
you